John koukla author of a wilderness so
immense where's that title come from
part of its devoted based on a quote but
we kind of adapted it from from a
quotation which people talk about the
immensity of the of the wilderness it's
actually a federalist who was who was
appalled that the that the Democratic
Republicans under Jefferson had bought
the place he didn't he was he was
against it so I was kind of a fun part
of the the irony of using that in the in
the quotation place i should say is the
Louisiana Purchase and the destiny of
America which is a subtitle yes sir when
did we as a country by Louisiana we
bought it in by treaty in in April of
1803 what was it it was the Western
watershed of the Mississippi River and
the and what they call them the Isle of
arlene's which is basically the city of
New Orleans or mountain now Orleans
Parish of the city of New Orleans and so
it's it's basically something depending
on how you count them up 13 states and
little parts of a couple of others sell
from but you just drew a line from if
you went from if you went from from New
Orleans north to Minnesota and Canada
and west of the Rockies why did we buy
it we bought it because because it was
offered to us it was really that vast
territory was really incidental to what
the United States really wanted which
was simply the city of New Orleans of
Port of New Orleans because the Port of
New Orleans controls the navigation of
the not only the Mississippi River but
also the Ohio River and at that point of
course the United States was was was all
east of the Mississippi River and the
farmers and merchants in Kentucky and
Tennessee were desperate to have the use
of the Ohio River to export their crops
what did we pay for it we paid 15
million dollars although you say in your
book by the time all the interest is
paid it was what police have yet they
financed it for 20 years at six percent
so by the time it gets by the time that
all the notes are paid off in in 1823
it's it's about 27 million and that's
where when you hear that it was four
cents an acre that's that's the figure
that they're using for that computation
how big a deal was it then
it was an enormous steel Jefferson was
just flabbergasted when when the word
came back at they at the extent of a
piece of property that had been
purchased and and he wrote a number of
letters he got word right roughly around
the third of July 1803 wrote a number of
letters and the responses from people
that he wrote to are interesting because
the half a dozen of those of those folks
make the comparison that the Louisiana
Purchase is equal in importance to the
declaration of independence and to the
writing the Constitution why well but
what it did is it secured the it secured
the Western watershed of the Mississippi
River and use the Mississippi River and
in that way it put it into the regional
tensions that basically could have split
the country at the peak of the
Appalachian Mountains because the
Westerners desperately needed to use the
use the river and there had been some
separatist movements in the 1780s in the
in Kentucky and Tennessee so it's
secured it secured that the use of that
river and then of course it also it also
meant that the nation was going to be
able to expand considerably across the
continent to the Rockies without having
a neighbor on that side of the West how
many people lived inside the territory
at the time there were about 50,000 very
relatively small population are exempt
now that that would be 50,000 Europeans
yeah is relatively small in fact a part
of part of the pressure that the Spanish
had being exerted on them in the in the
decade in before the Louisiana Purchase
is is one of population position and
there's a significant movement of people
over the mountains into Kentucky
Tennessee so if you start immediately
after the American Revolution let's say
1785 there's roughly 30,000 Americans
who have gone over the mountains into
Kentucky and Tennessee and there's
roughly 30,000 French Spanish
inhabitants of Louisiana by by 1800 the
Louisiana has got about 50,000 but the
numbers in Kentucky Tennessee route
roughly 326 million this I have 23 and
26 thousand
yeah so you know it's like the increase
in population is like seven or eight
fold at least these sentences got my
attention on page four Thomas Jefferson
and I'll take this slowly never traveled
west of the Shenandoah Valley mm-hmm
robert Livingston never got beyond the
Catskills mm-hmm James Monroe never made
it west of Erie Pennsylvania Napoleon
Bonaparte never visited America and his
ministers only the Atlantic coast and in
one of his ministers Francois is it barb
a barbell arbois once visited the Mohawk
Valley from his diplomatic post in New
York City during the last year's the
American Revolution and Charles Maurice
of Talleyrand right sat out the reign of
terror in Philadelphia why did you put
that in there at that what were you
point where you make the point that I
was making is that is that the story of
this diplomatic this diplomatic story is
the story of elite you know white
leaders making making decisions based on
based on information that they have to
glean from all kinds of sources but but
that they've never you know they never
they themselves never set foot in the in
the territories that were being affected
by their decision-making why should
anyone care about this and this 200th
anniversary I think there's I think
there's two reasons the one that jumps
to people's mind is the is the land
transaction you know besides and and
clearly that's that's phenomenally
important in American history because it
because it does reshape the continent of
North America when you think about it i
was i was working with it with a
documentary producer who was trying to
reach reach out to younger children and
he wanted me to speculate which is
something historians don't like to do
what he wanted me to speculate on what
North America would look like if there
hadn't been a Louisiana Purchase and and
you begin to if you play that game and
it's probably a legitimate game if you
play that game Canada's boundaries would
probably have extended down from sort of
like eerie to st. Louis there'd be a
Spanish or French
regime in charge of New Orleans and
what's now louisiana state of louisiana
state of arkansas and so on it's likely
that if the if the government under the
constitution of the 13 original states
if that if that government had not been
able to secure the navigation of the
mississippi and the Ohio rivers for the
Kentuckians and in Tennesseans they
probably would have split off and there
was a secessionist movement in New
England that probably would have pulled
it apart too and so we would have had a
you know we would have had a vulcanized
kind of map of North America with all of
the attendant irritants and abrasion
that goes with that so there's that
there's that Geographic response to the
significance the other significance is
one that I think is some is one that we
can now understand 200 years after the
event and that is the way in which to
engage in a broad caricature the first
200 years of American history from from
jamestown in 1607 to to the Louisiana
Purchase in 1803 created a white male
agrarian Protestant civic world on the
East Coast and at New Orleans in in 1803
that world confronted French Spanish pre
people of color which which was an
extraordinary shock to the American
understanding of race relations and so
on in an urban setting and and so I kind
of see that as a as a the beginning of
an encounter with diversity about 200
years ago and that that that did counter
with diversity through both through
integration and through expansion as
characterized you know the second 200
years of of American history so I think
for for those wealth of geographical and
the and the human dimensions I think
those are those are the two ways in
which i think it's it's worth you know
pausing to contemplate the significance
of this event how many books have you
written I've written a number of books
that have been you know monographs for
scholars this is the this is the first
time that I've written book length with
with the desire to reach a general
readership rather than just a few you
know few my peers or did you get the
idea the idea came to me when I was in
New Orleans I'd spent almost all most 20
years in Virginia studying Virginia
history and working in in Virginia and I
went and took a position in New Orleans
and I was completely bewildered as to
how that really you know fascinating
exotic and wonderful city how its
history related to the to the world of
18th century America that I had spent so
much time trying to figure out and
eventually I think being the book is my
answer to that to that question that was
puzzlingly but Arthur slicing or the
junior the Aaron had something to do
with this you say in your and yes yeah
what happened is I I'd been in 1993 we
played host I was I was then directly to
the historic New Orleans collection in
the French Quarter and we played host to
the celebrations of Jefferson's 250th
birthday and I got me to thinking about
the fact that the two 2003 was coming up
and that that some advance planning
might mean that there'd be Civic and
educational programs that that could be
put into place when the politicians
realized that there was an anniversary
within their term of office you know so
so I began bright I brought together
some people from universities and
museums in the in in Louisiana to begin
thinking about this and I also began
looking for a good book to read and when
I in 1998 i think it was i was found
myself on a program sitting next to
fresh flesh injure and and was picking
his brain because i had not found the
book that i wanted to read and and i
just i was i thought perhaps he might
know something that i'd missed and when
i said that i hadn't found it he
couldn't come up with any more titles
and I and I said you know I've been
thinking of writing it and he just he
just focused in on me just looked me
right in the island that would be a good
reason for you to write that book so so
how did you go about it I started by
that time I done a considerable amount
of reading and so so I simply began it I
as a writer I've always had to I'd
always had to write if I'm writing an
article I gotta get the first paragraph
if I'm writing a short piece you know I
have to get the first sentence I figured
that given the way I write what I needed
to do was nail down the first chapter
and so I so I wrote the first chapter
about the same time that I was working
up the book proposal
but you know for submission to
publishers to get the contract the one
with the title piece by piece yeah yeah
that was that was my initial initial
initial initial draft yeah he started
it's been reworked you know over the
over the subsequent months of course the
skies over Paris were cloudy on
Wednesday January 25th 1786 and the
early morning temperature was 42 degrees
in the courtyard of the elegant new
mansion on and on how long does it take
you to start that and why start that way
I wanted one of the things that I it
took quite a while to figure out
although somehow that the fact that
Jefferson for 50 years of his life took
the temperature twice a day and if you
look at his commonplace books he did
this I mean I if I decided to do you
know exercises or something like that
for you know I I might go a week with
some regularity but for 50 years of his
life six days out of seven he did get
the temperature in the morning and it's
like five days out of seven that on
average city that he got the temperature
written down in the afternoon and it was
just fascinated with weather and of
course that was a way it could work and
somehow that just that just spoke to me
about I don't know discipline though it
was something that just was kind of
quirky and fascinating about him and and
then the other thing that I wanted to do
in that chapter was was try to try to
try to have a starting place for the
story and it seemed to me that that what
what happens that particular what I
focused on is two days in Jefferson's
life when he's a master to Paris
ambassador France in Paris and in in one
of those letters so that he writes he
writes a series of letters that day and
one of the letters he he writes and he's
basically surveying the state of affairs
in Europe so that was a perfect
mechanism to kind of take stock of the
situation of the world at the beginning
of my story but the other one is a
letter that he writes to a protege
really in Virginia in which he's kind of
speculating about the future of the
continent and particularly about the
fact that that many of these western
territories are in hands of the Spanish
and he any rights that that he hopes
that the Spanish can hold these
territories long enough
us to pluck them from them piece by
piece so there it is 17 years ahead of
the event my math is right and he's
already he's already contemplating in
his mind the inevitability of American
acquisition of what was then Spanish
territory so that seemed to be a good
place to start and you know when we
learn about the exam purchase right here
about Napoleon we always hear about
France owning it but you spend a lot of
time back and forth and back and forth
Spain de France and give us a quick
history hon who owned that land sure
Louisiana was was founded about 1699 by
the French and was named for for King
Louie the 14th and then the in the at
the end of the seven years war or in
American history the French and Indian
War the the French gave it to the
Spanish in order to keep from having to
surrender to Britain they'd essentially
lost in North America to Great Britain
lost Canada for example so the Spanish
took possession and administrative
Louisiana from the 1760s up until just
weeks weeks before the Americans took
possession of it in 1803 so that that
Spanish domination of Louisiana's is is
often is often missed you know it's the
you go you go visit Louisiana for the
longest time you ride the streetcars
down st. Charles Avenue for the longest
time when I first got to Louisiana I
figured that st. Charles Avenue that was
probably named for Charlemagne well in
fact it's named for for Carlos the third
who was king of King of Spain right at
right on the eve of the Louisiana
Purchase that takes into chapter 2 you
start by saying in the game in Chapter
Carlos the third hunted nearly every
afternoon from one o'clock till dusk
yeah roaming the countryside in pursuit
of wolves and foxes that preyed on his
subjects farms and livestock why the
hunting thing I guess didn't his son it
was Costa for you son yeah Thomas afford
hunted too he he Carlos the fourth was
the kind of guy who'd like to have have
the keepers run the deer past the Royal
stand and blast at him whereas Karl
Carlos the third the father actually
enjoyed going out and
and tracking and hunting down wolves so
he was I think he was a real hunter
rather than just you know somebody's
butt but the butt to get back to your
question the Carlos Palace a third was
an amazingly able monarch and and I
Wendy rain he came to the throne in the
1750s Spain Rob Spain yeah and and he
died in 1788 so he you know he's there
and in charge of Louisiana at the time
when I'm starting the story calling the
Catholic King yes they that's that's the
term that they used his his most
Catholic Majesty was the kind of let
formal language that shows up in
treaties referring to the king of King
of Spain you say that his death though
probably led to the sale eventually in
Louisiana I think well what happens is I
think arguably Carlos the third the
father is one of the most able monarchs
and probably in all of Spanish Spanish
history and his son has I think an
equally strong claim to be one of the
most inept and so it it makes a you know
it makes a big difference that that you
have a less able man facing like
challenges of the French Revolution and
ultimately of Napoleon when did Carlos
three died well you know I don't
remember the exact date he was he was
forced into exile in 1808 I think he
lived on into the 1820s but I don't have
exact date in mind when it his son take
over then hit the car I'm sorry Carlos
the third died in 1788 and then his son
took over in 15 oz yeah yeah yeah and
then the Sun eventually get you know
Napoleon kicks the ball of the Bourbons
off the off the Spanish throne in 1808
and puts his brother on the Spanish
throne and sends these guys into exile
that stuff that isn't you know I didn't
I didn't I didn't follow that that
digression in the beginning of your book
you list the number of people you
thought were the principal characters in
this whole exchange one of them was
robert Livingston who was he robert
robert Livingston was a New York
politician who statesman and he was
Jefferson's minister to France he'd been
active in in in the revolution he was
known them in New York history as
Chancellor
extent to separate to distinguish him
from a whole bunch of Robert Robert was
a really popular name in the Livingston
family in fact this guy's name was
robert robert Livingston but he had been
he'd been foreign minister for the
Continental Congress in in the in the
American Revolution and so was
experienced in in in diplomacy and alike
and was Jefferson's choice to to go
represent the United States to do to
France when Jefferson came to the
presidency you I wrote a stallion say
Robert Levinson made the deal and James
Monroe saved it mm-hmm Livingston had
worked on the idea of trying to get a
hold of New Orleans he had been working
on that for months and then late in that
late in the game Monroe arrives with
with special authority to negotiate for
those purposes Monroe I don't think ever
realized how much work Livingstone had
done it before his arrival and so kind
of had an inflated notion of what he had
done because as far as what Monroe saw
he he arrived they went through three
weeks of negotiation they ended up with
a treaty and it looked like you know it
looked like that's when it all happened
but but as I as I think I pretty well
document in the book Livingston had
worked long and hard in order to in
order to create the situation in which
the treaty came about the the sentence
that says that Monroe saved it what
happened is after the treaty has been
signed and sent back to united states
for ratification that summer napoleon
began to have second thoughts and it was
at that point that Monroe who had was
even closer to Jefferson than Livingston
and had been with him more recently and
so on had the self-confidence to say
we've been authorized to spend two
million dollars let's give it to him and
living said was not sure that that was a
good idea you know turn over two million
dollars to somebody who's about to back
out of a deal you know what happens when
Monroe insisted that this was the right
thing to do and and and only Monroe
could have done that because he was you
know closer to you can you could argue
about whether Monroe or Madison is
closer to Jefferson but you know
was he was basically very very close
personally and politically to Jefferson
and so he had the wherewithal to to say
let's let's do it and that did in fact I
think it quelled those fears that
Napoleon would try to back out of the
treaty do me a favor before we lose you
entirely your mic is about to fall I'll
just slide it back up there and it's up
a little higher so we so we can hear you
sometimes they fall sometimes they fall
off in the middle of your step another
name was talleyrand yeah talleyrand is a
fascinating character in French history
he starts off as a bishop and then he
leaves the church on the eve of the
French Revolution he's part of that
first early kind of aristocratic and
liberal or rather than extreme period of
the first years of the French Revolution
he's a major figure in writing the
Declaration of the Rights of Man and
citizen in fact it's interesting a very
well stem craft when she writes about
the vindication of the rights of women
dedicates Talia ran because he puts
women into the Declaration of Rights and
citizen and then and then he gets you
know gets a foul of the more extreme
elements in the in the Revolution when
the reign of terror is about to start
and is able to escape under a diplomatic
mission to to England and then
ultimately go to our comes and sits out
the reign of terror in in Philadelphia
which he liked about as well as WC
Fields did he didn't care for the
Liddell fee at all but what happens then
after after the reign of terror is that
the talleyrand whose real forte is
Foreign Relations comes back and gives
two lectures one at the French Institute
they're very very well received and
published one of the lectures advocates
religious liberty as a way of
establishing this stable government by
simply trying to get the the issue of
religious dissension and contention out
of politics so he advocates religious
liberty and the other is the advocates
colony
as a way of rebuilding the French Empire
and also as a convenient place to send
you know malcontents and and
particularly what he's thinking about is
you know the poll Ian's got all of these
victorious soldiers who you know what
are you going to do with him when peace
comes of course as it turns out Napoleon
never never has to worry about peace but
what talleyrand's thinking about that
and so he so he reintroduces the idea of
colonization and then that leads in turn
to he and Napoleon kind of get connected
he supports Napoleon and the coup that
brings Napoleon and office and Napoleon
makes him his foreign minister and and
you know Napoleon is one of his one of
his goals is to try to reestablish the
the French domination of Haiti which was
then sand emang that the sugar colony
there which had had such an enormous
role in the French economy and so what
the polling wants to do is is send an
expedition to conquer conquer sand emang
or modern Haiti put down the revolt of
the slaves the reinstitute slavery and
get that sugar economy working again and
tali reigns kicked ellerines pretty much
all for that and in fact this is what
causes Napoleon to be interested in
Louisiana he wants to use Louisiana as a
place to supply food and firewood and
all kinds of mundane commodities that
aren't very profitable that basically
the idea is that you don't want to you
don't want to waste slave labor and
expensive land in this you know tropical
plantation economy of Haiti which can be
put to use making you know making sugar
particularly but also coffee indigo and
chocolate that stuff's profitable so the
idea is that you bring in bringing these
other mundane supplies from Louisiana so
that's that's that's Napoleon this is
kind of an imperial vision and that's
why he presses the Spanish to to cede
Louisiana back to him
1800 do I remember you saying that that
sugar was like twenty percent of the
gross national product of France yeah
it's something like that and it had a
phenomenal role in in French overseas
trade basically what what happened is
that they would they would bring the
sugar in from from from San demand
particularly but also I mean Martinique
also had it and and the British were
frankly doing the same thing in Barbados
and and Jamaica but they would the
French would bring it in in and then
process it and and market it throughout
Europe so it represented something like
sixty percent of the of the foreign
shipping of the French shipping trade it
was a phenomenal phenomenal important
part of the French economy let's go back
to kind of the dates and try to lay that
groundwork 1803 was when we want to sign
right okay right when did it when did
somebody start planning to want to get
the Louisiana territory in this country
in this country well Livingston was
working on that that idea early on but
here this would be 1800 living
livingston livingston when livingston
went to Jefferson is elected in 1800
takes office in 1801 so when when
Livingston goes to France in in 1801
part of what he's interested in is
trying to secure you know well I should
say actually say when when the Americans
learn that the that the Spanish are
ceding Louisiana back to the French it's
at that point that Livingston and the
Americans start working on the idea if
we you know we can't let this happen so
Thomas Jefferson became president 1801
how is he then he was let's he was more
than 43 so he's was born in 1743 so he's
like 59 60 and he spent how many years
in France my name is he had been there
from 84 to 89 so you didn't spend about
five years five and a half years okay
then if you just step back a little bit
you have great britain at noontime in
1801 who is running great britain then
georgia third and how big how many
people live there
what I'm not sure what maybe 30 40
million I've no I would I would I would
guess France was run by France with this
at in 1801 France was was being run by
Napoleon it had it had gone from from
Louis the sixteenth and who was beheaded
at the beginning of the revolution that
had gone through a whole bunch of
turmoils in different forms of
government and and Napoleon was first
console in in 1801 and then of course in
a later on in the early in 18 for he
crowns himself Emperor you say he had a
constitution change then they started up
two votes yes it did yeah apparently
that's one of the things his brothers
did a great job of manufacturing these
phenomenal victories at the at the
ballot box that in fact were all frauds
you have any idea how many people live
in France in 1801 no I don't Cuba was on
by what country Cuba was owned by Spain
in fact Cuba was kind of the base of
their administration of the Caribbean
area florida florida was on by spain
canada canada had had been owned by
france but as a result of Seven Years
War the french-indian war had been
transferred to Great Britain when do you
bring in general Wilkinson Wilkinson
shows up in the story in in about 1785
he'd been involved in the in various
things in the revolution need the
thought of the revolution is originally
from Maryland and it started it started
off thinking he was going to be a
physician but he got interested in and
became a soldier and and he goes to he
goes to out to Kentucky in 1785 and one
of the things that he tries to agitate
for is is is opening the river the
rivers periodically being closed it had
been open it because the Spanish were
surreptitiously helping the Americans
during the revolution and then went
through revolution is over they they
close to the info Wilkinson Wilkinson
gets gets all of these Kentucky farmers
to donate a whole several boat loads
worth of stuff and he and he floats at
downstream
with the idea that he's going to open
the open the Ohio Mississippi River
tradelink and then when he gets down
there he starts negotiating with with
the governor of Louisiana with with his
his scheme he portrays himself as
someone who can who is going to be able
to bring Kentucky out of the Union and
and and join it with with with the
Spanish administration in New Orleans
and therefore make it you know kind of a
defensive measure so he sort of playing
both sides against against the middle
and what he what it what it seems that
he really wants is to is to develop a
trade monopoly where he would be the
only one who who had the authority to
bring Kentucky goods down down the river
which were of course wouldn't you know
very very lucrative but he kind of plays
both sides against the river and the the
Spanish I don't think the Spanish really
after a while they don't believe that
that he's capable of bringing Kentucky
out of the Union but but he's his
information is useful and so they keep
him on the payroll you know you know
past the time in Louisiana Purchase he's
he's on the Spanish payroll his secret
number was he was nothing agent number
13 because that's the the code that they
used with logan sins so he's quite a
character somebody ought to somebody
really ought to write a good book about
Wilkinson it's been 30 years and the
Spanish archives are now available in a
way that they weren't under Franco so
have you thought about yourself that's
that's I can make it through Spanish
documents with a dictionary and I can
run them by friends who who could make
sure that the transcriptions are good
but but i'm not sure that i wanted once
you get into an archive and you have to
deal with both the handwriting and the
language i'm not sure that i could
master that one but the relation and
that by the way you have some canada in
your background yeah I went to I went to
graduate school the University of
Toronto and and did a minor in Canadian
history so I've you know kind of done in
graduate school I did American Canadian
and British history is alive or you can
memorize originally from Wisconsin and
where did you go to Ana grant Carthage
College in Kenosha it's a small Lutheran
related liberal arts school on the lake
michigan and how
you get interested in history I had a
good teacher and that was a Nelson Peter
Ross the late nelson p ross where he was
at that carthage he he was just kind of
turned me on to the discipline and the
other thing was i could never decide as
an undergraduate I couldn't decide what
I wanted it you know what I wanted to
major in and so I convinced myself that
if I majored in history since that would
be everything everything under the Sun
from yesterday back I could put off you
know put off having to having to you
know narrow my focus and you know it's
some way in some ways that's been true
i've done a you know had had a lot of
fun looking into a lot of interesting
things what was it town that you grew up
in and was kind i picked my parents were
teachers so we moved around a lot as dad
went up to the ranks but they're they're
originally from milwaukee and they're
living now in jefferson i spent most of
high school in town called for twitches
up near eau claire there is some
reference in here about you I think
standing on the Mississippi yes yeah
what was that yeah when when I was some
when I was a child my folks when I was
five I guess they were teaching in a
little town called verndale minnesota
north of minneapolis and one summer we
went up north of verndale to to Lake
Itasca I have no real honest memories of
Lake Itasca which is the which is the
headwaters of the Mississippi River but
I remember seeing the photograph of
myself and my sister at Lake Itasca what
I do have an actual memory of his is up
in Bemidji they have these big big
statues at a park there of Paul Bunyan
and babe the Blue Ox that I remember
right you know that's that's an actual
memory rather than rather than a one
that's been helped along with a
photograph so what did your career I
mean what have you done in your life
since then well after graduate school I
went to Virginia to work on Virginia
history and ended up editing a magazine
that was then published by the library
Virginia called Virginia cavalcade and
became the director of research and
publishing at the library Virginia which
I did from I guess well I started with a
library Virginia in 73 and left in 1992
take
of this dark norleans collection so I
spent you know 17 17 years doing doing
Virginia history and library of
Virginia's were its enrichment it's it's
to it is to its to the seat of
government the equivalent of the library
Congress and the archives it's both it's
both the library and archives for the
Commonwealth of Virginia and what are
you doing now right now I'm the director
of the Patrick Henry Memorial Foundation
which is at Patrick Henry's last home
and in his burial place about 100 miles
south of Richmond called red hill and
what's that foundation do today we we
basically have taken it upon ourselves
to be the kind of major interpreter of
you know of Patrick Henry in the same
way that the Mount Vernon you know
claims Washington and both preserves a
site related to him or Monticello does
the same thing for Jefferson both both
preserving a site thats related to that
man and also trying to do educational
programs and the like that that simply
you know are there to inform people of
what what he stood for and what role he
played in history what kind of money do
you spend every years in a foundation
like that Oh ours ours is very small and
the comparison with with either Mount
Vernon or Monticello as is one of a nap
to a giant believing we've we've got
we've got four four full-time people and
I think the budget is roughly about 25
to 50 thousand a year what kind of money
do you have to raise or what kind of
lays a foundation have it and who gives
to a patrick henry foundation in today's
we've got we've got a lot of people who
support Patrick Henry for his
involvement in Bill of Rights and we've
got a lot of people who support Patrick
Henry because they see him as a
spokesperson for limited government
which you know both of those things
being being positions that he that he
held not only in his arguments with with
the king and and before the Revolution
but also but also in ratification
debates over over whether or not to rat
Constitution so I think those are the
two things that are you know what what
kids remember in four courses you know
is give me liberty or give me death and
it enters an interesting interesting
character because he was so prominent in
American mind in the 19th century at a
time when you know the country still
valued oratorio as a not only as a part
of political debate but also his
entertainment and and and because he was
a man not a man of the pen he's been
kind of eclipsed by those people who
left voluminous writings by the way the
cover of your book where is this
painting from the painting at leaves in
Cincinnati you know did it Asher Durand
I think what I must say that they that
the folks at the at copps art department
are the ones that that located that
particular painting in the pursuit of
this subject the subtitle being the
Louisiana Purchase and the destiny of
America where did you go where did you
travel where did you study I hoped at
one point Brian that I would have to go
to Madrid but i but I was spared that
owners trip by a by microfilm had at
Tulane and and the resources here at the
library Congress University Virginia
library Charlottesville and Library of
Virginia and others so most of my most
of my travels were actually east of the
Mississippi in two parts of the of the
territory that I had not previously
visited I just the the Kentucky and
Tennessee yeah and and and in
Mississippi was now the state of
Mississippi they they figure you know
prominently and a lot of a jostling that
goes it goes on in the kind of
background to it and there were just
parts of that territory that I was
unfamiliar with and then there were
archives there that I had had not
occasion you so in 1999 I took about a
seven week research trip in which I just
wandered I had you know some some
destinations in
in in mind archives in mind and
collections that I wanted to use but i
also would would just you know whatever
i saw those brown signs of marker local
museums i stopped at those sort of
things and what i was trying to do was
to try to keep from making mistakes I'm
not sure that I mean certainly I learned
things but for example members stopping
in in Chattanooga and I could I had
never quite figured out how Chattanooga
fit in with it because it's not part of
the early history Tennessee doesn't get
treated one and you know I went so I
went in this local museum and the first
first panels in there have to do with
with the Cherokee dominance of that part
of it I was like oh yeah you know until
until they were until Jackson kicked
them out that's where they were no
wonder it's not a place of you know of
extensive European settlement in Sadie
you know 1800 and so he was it was I did
a lot of that kind of traveling did
drove the at one time I thought that the
Natchez Trace would figure in the story
I'm not even sure that frankly gets
mentioned well that's that's the road
that runs from Nashville to Natchez and
or I guess we really should say from
Natchez to Nashville it's the road that
after the Louisiana Purchase it's the
road that was used by a lot of the
Tennessee and Kentucky farmers who would
float their goods down to market and
then dismantle the boat and sell the
lumber and then get to make their way up
to Natchez and then go either by horse
or by foot back to back up into into the
bluegrass country this sentence and I
know you noticed talking about me when
you read these books it's always fun to
read these kind of sentences this
remarkable document perrin which has
never been published or consulted by
American Historians perrin confirms
Monroe's suspicions quote not finding a
better occasion is it guard dokie guard
okie is our dummy who was he was the
Spanish ambassador to the United States
and the Cayman he arrived in 1785 so
he's there right before the writing the
Constitution okay quoting again not
finding a better occasion
dokie road I take advantage of the
French male to tell you that we are in a
critical time never in Congress has
there been a controversy more combated
than that of our mississippi mm-hmm
where did you find this and why is it
why historians not consulted it why is
it never been published it's it that's a
that's a great story and thanks for
asking um there's a there's been a
contention with what's the background
here is that there the Monroe wrote
letters to actually to Patrick Henry
when he was then he happened to be
governor of Virginia at the time does
chamber unrolls go James Monroe was in
congress james monroe from Congress this
is in 1785 and 1786 any writes letters
to patrick henry reporting on for the
congressional delegation as to what was
going on and he describes what what's a
seat you know what's what seemed in is
if his letters at face value to be a
movement on the part of a bunch of
particularly massachusetts but also a
few connecticut congressmen to work with
Jon Jay in order to in order to get a
Spanish commercial treaty they were
willing to close the Mississippi River
give up the navigation Mississippi River
for 25 or 30 years the the Virginians
were adamantly opposed to this why were
they willing to give it up they well
from the point of view of mass of
Massachusetts they first of all I didn't
think it was important secondly they
they were not eager to have the lands to
the West become profitable because it
only meant that farmers from
Massachusetts might might believe or
that prospective factory workers might
go out or seamen and sailors might go
out so so the the idea of opening the
West was not anything that that folks in
Massachusetts or particularly John J
wrote on the number of cases this is not
something that he thought the country
was ready for and what was john j dì
john j at this time was he was the
principal see whose it was a foreign
minister said foreign secretary he was
he was the basic he was the equivalent
for the for the congressional Congress
before the for congress before the
adoption of the present constitute
he was basically the equivalent of
Secretary of State and so he was the one
who was deputed to negotiate with the
Spanish ambassador and in this document
was again this doc what happened Brian
is that is that there's there's been
this Henry letter so people knew of and
most people dismiss this is just being
you know hyperbole that Monroe was just
exaggerating because because his
contention frankly was that that the
that the New Englanders were trying to
close the river and push this push the
southerners out of the Union well what
what I found in a in it there's a big
the authoritative big biography of james
monroe there was a footnote to a
dissertation done in 1948 about guard
okie the the the spanish minister so I
got the dissertation on interlibrary
loan and and read through the thing and
at the bottom of one of the pages
there's a mention of this letter that
had something to do with Gardocki
meeting with New Englanders and then in
turn i was able from that i was able to
find a in inventory that had been
published in the 1940s ni and i faxed a
request to the archives in in seville
and they sent me a photo copy of the two
letters that i wanted in which in which
this spanish ambassador is talking about
his secret meetings with with a haanta
from El Norte and it sort of thing and
it was at that point that I you know
enlisted the assistance of good friends
who do Latin American history to make
sure that we got the translation right
you know but basically what what he was
doing in his dispatches the Spanish
ambassador in his dispatches back to
back to the authorities in in Spain was
confirming the fact that he was
consulting secretly with with some of
these new englanders hey you know this
is a very complicated story yes yeah
absolutely absolutely yeah how did you
keep track how did I keep trying to all
these people all these you know it well
you know actually what's not what
started with my in that road trip that I
mentioned is I would buy the
those kind of milk carton things that's
used for files well I bought two of
those and they fit in my trunk and
actually by the end of the trip I could
fit three of them in my trunk by the end
of the book I think I've got a dozen of
them and I've got him kind of arranged
you know there's there's a couple of
them that have to do with France and a
couple of them that have to do with
Jefferson a couple of them that so
basically I've got the I've got the
files and essentially what i did the way
i did most of my research was was by
whenever possible for copying things so
I had it to go back to in in the back of
the book you published some appendix or
appendices you have one is it proposed
amendments to concert Constitution
that's right it ever happened no why
yeah what what happened is is Jefferson
had scruples about the constitutionality
of Louisiana Purchase and the thing that
most people jump to of course is you
know that there wasn't there wasn't the
authority to buy this big piece of land
Jefferson wasn't terribly troubled about
the the land the land deal and and it
what the language that he used to
describe the situation is that this was
beyond the Constitution I mean his
basically feeling basic feeling was that
you know had that had the guys at
Philadelphia thought that anything like
this could have happened they would of
course written it in and so on and he
contemplated writing writing on an
amendment to Constitution to kind of
sanction what what had been done the
trouble that that he and others had was
in bringing into the Union all of these
people who were not accustomed to the
Democratic ways of American society who
didn't speak English who had been you
know who were Catholics and so on and
that's that's you know bringing those
people into the union was what what
trouble Jefferson Tom and the other new
orlean the people the people in
Louisiana inhabitants of Louisiana today
had mixed marriages there yeah they had
they had in fact they had a substantial
proportion of the population of New
Orleans who were free people of color
who were recognized as having a role in
society and Marilyn white and very white
sand like yeah I mean is there Caribbean
kind of path one of your settings here
is that this was the beginning of a
vegetable diversity versity yeah I think
so yeah I by buying the Louisiana
Purchase yeah
it took this you know white male
Protestant nation and suddenly you know
it had had to deal with the reality of
people with in large numbers in one big
events with people who are very
different from what most Americans
thought of as you know I mean there's
they're certainly not they're there
they're not Boston former Puritans and
they're not Jefferson's yeoman farmers
and my way for folk that when did we get
floor and I know this is out of context
Florida we get we get Florida in in the
treaty negotiations of 18 18 and 18 19
which kind of tidy up all is that it
takes that long to trying to tidy up all
the lines of Louisiana Purchase we had a
very good at that point um no so we
didn't have to pace paying anything for
that I don't think so I don't think so
all right now another out of context
question I kept selling I can't thinking
of a hotel bathroom when you told us
during the bathrooms yeah yeah the three
Napoleon's yeah not you know you got
it's it's it's possible that this is
greatly exaggerated and maybe even
apocryphal because it it shows up in one
of Napoleon's brothers memoirs published
you know after the fact and it's it's
pretty clear that he's you know
embellished it a little bit because
there's a point but but the story is
basically the British were trying to
bribe Napoleon's brothers in order to
keep him from buying Louisiana because
they figured that would get him involved
in in the Caribbean and it would tie him
down and so on so at what point are we
and we're we're in 1802 early 1803 the
Spanish control right now Spanish
they're still in control but it's well
known that the Napoleon has signed the
treaty and is going to be taking
possession and so so what happens
supposedly after well after one of the
performance at the Opera these the two
brothers descend on Napoleon finded
bathing in the in rose water and begin
to her its Joseph and Lucien Joseph and
Lucien yet Joseph is the elder brother
Lucian's a younger brother and what are
they doing what's there there Joseph
both of them are involved
politics Lucien is is in the National
Assembly and is one who had been been
fixing the elections and Joseph you know
Josephus is also involved in politics
although not quite as not quite as
actively I guess and the idea is that
they're going to try to convince
Napoleon not to not to sell Louisiana
and particularly they were they were
fearful and Lucien it takes the lead
here they were just appalled that that
that Bonaparte was going to do this on
his own without consulting the
legislature and you know they part of
this is self-interest they're concerned
that he's going to get himself in such
trouble that you know that the whole
Bonaparte family gets itself kicked out
us out of out of France and so on and so
there's this this argument that goes on
and eventually they're shouting at one
another and and and bonaparte falls back
into the tub and rose water splashed
everywhere and one of the valets is
supposed to you know he's supposed to
have fainted and after this huge splash
Lucien quotes something out of some
classical source having to do with with
calming the Seas that's the part that I
think probably got got dressed up
afterwards when he was writing it in his
memoirs but it's a it's a it's a great
it's a great story and what it what it
what it demonstrates is that is it at
that point in in the which is actually
before Monroe arrives in in Paris that
Bonaparte was absolutely committed to
the idea of selling Louisiana so when
the dust settles on this story who in
your opinion made the biggest difference
I think I think Jefferson's handling of
this of you know whatever whatever you
want to say about any other parts of
Jefferson's career and there are other
brilliant parts and others that people
argue about but his handling of the
diplomacy of the
of the Louisiana Purchase is absolutely
brilliant it's just absolutely brilliant
he DS he decides that he wants to bring
about a peaceful resolution of it he
uses he uses his his representatives
both Livingston and Monroe beautifully
he also uses a peer Samuel to punt
there's a kind of a back-channel
messenger to to the people around
Napoleon he he just he just he just
plays this beautifully at this time
there are no cell phones there is no
telegraph there's nothing there's no
mail takes how long it takes roughly
four weeks for a message to you know you
can pretty much count on a message
getting across the Atlantic in four
weeks sometimes longer it takes three or
four weeks for a message to get from New
Orleans to Washington you know so yeah
well there's there's no relatives
there's no cell so one of the one in
Jefferson I think part of the part of
the key here Brian is that Jefferson had
been an ambassador he'd been in France
trying to represent his nation for five
years you know with these with these
same limitations on communication so
what he does when he appoints Livingston
as he takes Livingston to into his
office and they spend several days
together going over I guess we'd call
them alternate scenarios so that by the
time Livingston goes to France he knows
Jefferson's mind he knows how how you'd
react to this that or the other thing
when he gets a chance to send Monroe he
does the same thing but brings Monroe to
his office they spend a week by the time
those guys get over there they know
Jefferson's mind they know what he wants
they know how he'd react because they
played all these things out kind of in
speculation and so they and they've got
his full confidence and and they do a
magnificent job you know if it the other
thing is he doesn't he doesn't give him
carefully you know detailed limiting
written instructions so that it's not
like when when the French say we'd like
to sell you the whole territory they're
able to say okay the month in 1803 that
again at the treaty was signed treaty
was treaty was negotiated in april and
was it was dated April thirtieth and
they said what with it Senate passed it
in in in three readings because because
because Napoleon was said to be having
second thoughts Jefferson wanted push
what the house to the house the house
didn't have the court the house doesn't
have to ratify the treaty I know but
said in jobs that there was yes
subsequently what happened is when when
the legislation comes before Congress
for the governance of Louisiana then
there are very extensive debates when
when does Thomas Jefferson turn to
Meriwether Lewis and William Clark and
say I want you to go out there the work
the work on the preliminary work with
with Meriwether Lewis had started prior
to Louisiana Purchase Jefferson brought
into Washington as his personal
secretary among other things and was and
then was working on that and in fact as
I do one of the chapters in the
background is a story of an earlier
precursor of the of the Lewis and Clark
expedition in in 1793 when Jefferson
wanted to engage a French botanist named
Andre me show in 1793 he wanted to send
him from st. Louis up to up to Missouri
River for for a variety of reasons that
that didn't come about but Jefferson
used the same the same instructions
recycled the instructions when he
dropped drafted the instructions for
Lewis and Clark all right it's a little
light in this but the George Rogers
Clark William Clark connection and
George Rogers Clark did what in all this
George Rogers Clark had been basically
had conquered the West for the United
States during the during the American
Revolution and so he was known as the
kind of hero of the West he'd held the
Illinois Territory against the British
during the American Revolution and then
basically retired from service he was
the state of Virginia never paid his
bills and the poor man was was driven
into the poorhouse and bankruptcy by the
by the bean counters in Richmond but
then but then he was being approached by
the French revolutionaries and so in the
1790s to with the idea that they might
lead an expedition down the Mississippi
River and take New Orleans William
Carter this other William William Fox
his younger brother and what was their
relationship they get along yeah they
get along they got along fine i mean
there's the considerable age difference
between the two of them but they got
they get along splendidly and as a
matter of fact William used to help his
brother out when when
because of all these debts that that had
been incurred George Rogers Clark
couldn't even accept land when they went
when the government tried to give him
land because it would get taken up out
of creditors so William did a lot of
that for France again out of context for
France abolish slavery in 1794 years oh
yes and when in fact did that have on
all this well it it had an enormous
impact on the debates over for example
over Haiti and San demanding and the
boat the ideals of the French Revolution
even before the actual abolition of
slavery fueled the aspirations of the of
the free people of color or the motto
group within within San tamang or Haiti
and led to the lead to the beginnings of
the civil war that then became a slave
uprising and of course that whole that
whole history of Santa million Haiti is
is an important it's an important part
of the story of Louisiana Purchase it's
a much more important part of American
history than people recognize at a time
you have another book I'm thinking about
it I'm kind of juggling juggling two and
haven't gettin rid the but yeah I've got
another book in the works but I'm not
sure which subject do you want to give
us a hand I'm thinking about writing
about Thomas Jefferson's relationship
with women a will earn is so immense is
the title of this book John kukla is our
guest and we thank you very much thanks
Brian